so it's great to talk to both of you I
really enjoyed the movie it was like a
year ago that I spoke to you for the
Lords of chaos and I and didn't realize
right after Sunday and see we're gonna
go film this right yeah no we were right
in prep when I saw you last time yeah
yeah so I guess I want to start with how
did you two first connect and what is it
like when you're both meeting each other
for the first time and you know what I
mean like is it I guess can you describe
what it was how you guys first connected
do you remember it
I do okay I came all the way to down
like to see it
from where from LA that's right I
thought he'd get from Sweden because
he's Swedish no long trip we had there
was just a graphic novel that came my
way at different timings it was on my
table couple years ago and then it
disappeared and then it came back and
then Jonas was attached and so he came
had a long meeting and talked about what
we lost about the graphic novel and how
to put that on
it was fantastic it was a rock'n'roll
meeting it was a lot of ideas yeah yeah
said yeah that was perfect I just
thought that let's let's go do it this
is soon it's a mad book and he seems
sufficiently mad to pull it off so
that's how he went for it
completely uh so you got the script
you're putting it together
how much changed along the way from
those initial meetings to what people
see on screen well quite a lot Mads came
with a back pack of notes that that was
the first thing he said to me and I
guess I guess I did too so there was
there was a lot of discussions a lot of
smart and great discussions how to
develop and add to make the story
stronger and how to figure out the
characters and all that so that was an
ongoing thing throughout the whole
process yeah yeah yeah and we I think we
from very early stage we were agreeing
that the stock we loved about the
graphic novel the the brutality the the
visual field to the whole thing was
something we definitely I mean that's
that was the key that was a base of the
story but at the same time we also
wanted to have something that was
weighing it up a little making it a slow
pace film two-degree and high paced film
to another degree and that those two
worlds morph together one of the things
I like is that your character is very
proficient at killing people but in the
real world he seems completely out of
place
yeah yeah that was the idea yeah yeah I
mean we thought that would be a I mean
interesting approach of not having a
character that was I mean he's super
skillful but we didn't want him to throw
around with what punch lines from
one-liners and be cool he might call a
laugh out once in a while but that's
because he sucks us what he's saying
he's really it's embarrassing what he's
saying what's real
with a movie like this the action
set-pieces they obviously matter because
people want to see you you know kicking
some ass so talk a little bit about the
way you guys work together in crafting
the action and where there's certain
things you were going for or to just
talk about crafting the action
set-pieces well we were well prepared of
course and the choreographed and ready
and I had I kind of had like a music
video approach to all the to all the
action sequences shooting a lot of
angles and preparing a lot for the Edit
Matt's insisted of doing very long takes
so the and it could have been very
different because we actually did very
long takes we also had to stunt double
standing by that would never worked
because he insisted of doing everything
himself you did a couple of things not
really what the role I had a issue with
my back okay well anyway yeah and of
course you know 25 below naked in the
snow you know it requires a lot of
preparation and all that stuff so one of
the things that again that we wanted I
mean even though he's highly skillful in
a certain time when he hasn't made you
fight he's not in the best stage he's
ever been in so we wanted it to be on
the verge of collapsing for a long long
time and you know so that's another guy
coming hopefully it's over there's
another guy coming it's not over yet
so we wanted it to be tired and not one
of these Duff but I was not you didn't
want this fight and it was a what we
call every fight that's what we're going
for
that also means obviously that we're to
do this starts you approach them
differently if it is it is a heavy form
before heavy on concrete so you can't
just get away with doing something slick
because the character was not that that
made it right yeah we wanted to look
like an earth I read in the notes that
one of the things you like about a
character is figuring out the clothing
that they're gonna wear and something
about you love the boots yeah
I loved his coat I was very much in love
with his - you know we went through that
a lot Susie and back and forth but I
think we were all generally lost wanted
to give him some weight some gravity we
wanted him - well he's got plenty of
money but he's not that interested in
wearing any right right so um so a man
who's just in it in a degree can mix him
until he opens his mouth jerk um I
definitely be curious about the editing
room and is ultimately the final rewrite
what did you learn from early screenings
for friends and family test screenings
that impacted the finished film actually
not as much as you would think on this
one because we were so we worked so hard
on the scripts in advance so it's very
much exactly what we shot actually it
didn't change much you have a lot of
deleted scenes no not at all a few
there's a few moments and a few
shortened moments and all that but no
nothing big a major that we took out
know I am a big for some reason and I
think the a lot of people like watching
like films that take place in the
criminal world hitmen who what is it
about the hitman genre or that seems to
relate so many people it's it's a tricky
question right I think of with probable
added numerous times I have this
philosophy that it's it's part of human
nature that you know we we invent God
and then five minutes later we invent
Satan we just needed we need that
balance we're so curious about what's
the other side of the coin and you
should explain it further we have to be
a psychologist
but there is a fascination for sure I
mean if this guy was
he's also checking out people we don't
like you know so that comes in handy
buddy but not all the time right so he's
been there forever right if he's a good
person and he's just doing his job we
can live with it if he's not a good
person and we hate him it's a different
thing
I'm a big fan of your work and I really
believe in what you're selling on screen
how do you typically like to prepare for
a role I mean when you're playing a role
like this are you doing something
different or is do you like an approach
for each of your movies it varies
slightly I guess but it the approach is
always over him and the script this is
what everything is about
this is the this is the base of
everything I might come up with small
ideas that has nothing to do with this
but the story and the way we approach it
together is is the vital key last
question for both of you I definitely
want to for people that aren't familiar
with Lords of chaos another film that I
really recommend that comes out soon can
you tell people a little bit about it
and also I believe you've got to work
with today Okajima on his upcoming game
which very excited for could you talk a
little bit about working with him and
the game let me do it first because
that's going to be short sure I can't
say anything on Monday but it's going to
be awesome
well and I can speak forever about Lords
of chaos so you better stop me no Lord
says kit Lords of chaos is finally
coming out it's actually coming out just
a couple of weeks after this one by the
way I recommend it to everyone
go on thank you thank you it's very
different from from polar it's actually
completely different and it's set in
Norway based on a true story about the
Norwegian black metal scene in the late
80s early 90s so I'll leave it at that
but again I can talk about forever if
you want me to yeah I I really it's
pretty dark and we could definitely talk
more of both of you thank you so much
for giving me your time have a fantastic
thank you so much
[Music]